[Music]
thanks for joining us American this is
the Dave Ramsey show open phones a
triple a eight two five five two two
five you can follow me on Twitter at
Dave Ramsey about 700,000 of you do
andrew says if there are two people both
serious about money and the first is
paying off a mortgage and the second is
renting and saving cash for a house
which is more wise well if we were going
to assume exactly the same sets of
income and exactly the same set of highs
of house to purchase the other thing
we'd have to assume to answer the
question correctly with math would be
that the rent was low very low and very
reasonable and it'll change the numbers
dramatically depending on the ratio of
house you're gonna buy to the income
that you have an example would be let's
say you wanted to buy a one hundred
thousand dollar house and you made a
hundred thousand dollars and you were
newly married and you lived in a garage
apartment out back at some rich old
lady's house for 250 bucks and so you
saved fifty thousand dollars a year for
two years in you bought a house for a
hundred thousand dollars cash
I think we would call that very wise
versus buying a house at the immediately
and paying it off over two or three or
in that case five years maybe now here's
why we would call that wise the way I
answer questions is what what I do if I
were in your shoes so it's a little bit
twisted to jump into this scenario endru
it would be detaii it's we haven't
bought a house yet do we take out a
mortgage or do we rent cheap and save up
and pay cash that's an apples-to-apples
comparison you can't say someone's
already bought a house and then paying
that off versus saving up to pay cash is
not apples to apples because them
selling the house you know might or
might not be the right thing to do in
other words I very seldom tell somebody
sell a house once they're in it
and as long as it's something they can
afford and instead just crank their way
through it and pay it off but but if
someone calls me and says hey should I
save up and pay cash before I buy my
house or should I buy renting cheap and
piling up a big pile of cash or should I
just buy now and paid off as fast as I
can and I would tell you save up and pay
cash for it I would call that the wiser
the way I know that the way I decided
that was again what would Dave Ramsey do
now the way I make my decisions on
almost anything if I can figure out what
the Bible says about it I do that and
the Bible does not say anything good
ever about debt there's not one time
it's mentioned positively in the Bible
every time debts mention you're a fool
you're a slave it's a bad idea it's a
curse
every time that debt is brought up
that's what it says now that's God
speaking as far as I'm concerned because
I'm a Christian and so I believe that
God is speaking there now I don't
believe that he's saying that you're
gonna go to hell if you get a MasterCard
or a mortgage it's not a Salvation issue
as a matter of fact I'm positive
scripture does not say that I also do
not even think that it's a sin some
people say debt is a sin I don't find
that in the Bible I just think it pretty
much says you're stupid
so biblically speaking debt is stupid
it's not a sin not a Salvation issue now
the only reason I let my foot off the
gas on that when someone's buying a home
here on the air it is to get a mortgage
you know a lot of people aren't going to
wait they're not gonna do the other
stuff we talked about anyway and so I I
just try to slow them down and keep them
as as tight as I can and then turn get
the house paid off as soon as possible
I however personally never borrow money
for anything in any circumstance you
cannot make me afraid or happy or greedy
enough to borrow money to go into a deal
you there's nothing I want that bad ever
I want to be debt-free more than there's
anything on the planet I want
we'll never trade that because it's
given me that much freedom it's given me
that much peace and I'm convinced as one
of the reasons I've become wealthy
there's not any stinking payments and
you don't have any payments you know
what you have money all the money's not
going out the door then when all you do
is make money and pay payments you're
broke you've lost control of your most
powerful wealth building tool which is
your income and the borrower is slave to
the lender so to answer your question
enter if we were looking at to say young
couples as an example that don't own a
home and they're at the they're at the
starting line who's wiser who's going to
end up ahead at the finish line if
they're sitting there one's gonna go buy
a house now and the others gonna rent
very inexpensively and save up and pay
cash for a home very very quickly not
over 30 years but over three or four or
five years they're gonna save up cash
and pay cash for their first home and
get started I'm gonna tell you that I
think the debt-free couple is going to
when they cross the finish line have
more money and that's because I believe
in God and I believe he says don't
borrow money and he wouldn't say that if
borrowing money worked now that sounds
pretty basic but here's the deal there's
tons of math to back that up and we can
we can approach this academically we can
approach it spiritually and I can show
you and I can walk you through a
bazillion ways but dude if you never I
talked to a guy last night I wasn't sure
now I went to a Christmas party last
night and I talked to a guy last night
that was worth almost a billion dollars
several hundred million dollars and he
comes up to me at this party and starts
telling me his story because he knew you
know what I do on the radio and I had
never met him before and he starts
telling me I've never borrowed a dime in
my life I've never had a car payment
I've never had a house payment
I started from nothing my parents were
dirt farmers I had nothing and I took a
job as a teacher making five thousand
eight hundred dollars a year in 1962 or
whatever it was and I took that money
and I saved and I paid cash for our
first
house and I saved on and paid cash for
our first little piece of dirt and I
built a house on that with cash and I
sold that house and he you know and then
I did this and then I did that and and
he just over the years has built his
wealth out of his cash flow and it's
grown exponentially and I meet more of
those than I do people who leveraged
their way into wealth borrowed their way
into wealth there's very few of those
occasionally I run into one but almost
not so that's it that's what it comes
down to the borrower is slave to the
lender and so I'm gonna tell you if I
can talk you into paying cash for
everything I'm going to try now Wells
Fargo is running an ad right now that
everybody's tweeting me with us you know
this goober on there saying don't listen
to the debt boogie man that the debt is
not a boogie man and of course that's
aimed at me
because I'm telling people deaths stupid
never borrow money never do owe money
and I also tell people never to go do
business with mega banks like Wells
Fargo I mean why would you do business
with a bank like Wells Fargo or Bank of
America or Chase I mean you're a number
they don't care about you they really
don't and truthfully most of the best
bankers in the business and I'm not
against bankers why would you do
business with a mega bank they're
horrible the customer service is
horrendous it's you know and then they
run ads like that you know it's like
Discover card or as a discover cards got
the freedom card that's so stupid
that's like government service a freedom
credit card that's an oxymoron DMV
service line if the DMV had a line that
said Fastlane for you to get your get
your paperwork done fast you know we all
know what that would mean it would be a
lie and so we know that's not gonna
happen
so think think think you know oh yeah of
course a banks it's gonna tell you
borrowing money's a good idea it's where
they make all their money is on VAR own
debt that's how they make everything of
course that's what they're going to say
thank the people why would you do
business with Wells Fargo anyway it's
just Dom this is the Dave Ramsey show